a
all right lovely
people hope everyone is doing
well hopefully you can see me and hear
me do you hear me my
people yes Miss wiked wolf caroan is
still under the weather she won't be
joining us for this stream um she send
SS her well wishes says hi to everybody
but no she won't be um around for this
one um but uh thank you for
asking this will brighten your day Matt
brunette of animat okay has checked out
your channel from his podcast followers
he posted your Spider-Man's abuse video
on his Facebook page
huh I am unfamiliar with this individual
I shall have to look into that
well thank you thank you for letting me
know actually you know
what I'm let's
see
Matt how do you spell that mat is
it
just one t oh oh there oh okay this guy
hang on play out
oh
Nifty cool
dang he
is uh more than double my size on
YouTube so yes that that's
lovely I I'm not always good at staying
on top of when my stuff gets boosted
elsewhere so I frequently miss when and
if stuff like that happens I think the
only time that I was aware of it because
it was such a big boost that I that I
couldn't possibly miss it was last
[Music]
year um I think last year no it would
have been
January I think I think it was January
either December or January and um
thought slime uh plugged one of my
videos uh well not on here one of the
ver wild Channel videos but still that
was
nice thank you for all the well wishes I
will pass them along belong to
her uh currently watching a documentary
on Charlie Chaplain that's narrated by
Pearl Mackey interesting choice of
narrator Charlie
Chaplan dude LED an interesting
life uh there's a lot to
unpack for better and worse with Charlie
Chaplain although I think that's
probably true of most major figures of
that point in time but it's not all bad
and that's kind of saying
something I have an appointment on
Saturday to get meds for my ADHD I hope
it goes well Tre witch I hope that
you're able to get a prescription that
is helpful to oh reminder to folks um I
will try and keep up with the chat the
only thing that guarantees that I will
address your comment or question is to
do it as a super chat which will also
get you a heart of of appreciation from
me I will try and keep up otherwise I
just can't make any promises
today's my friend Gracie's birthday
you're you have a lot of friends with a
lot of birthdays I feel like this comes
up
semi-regularly so that mold cider no no
it is not this is
water uh do you know if there are any
strike rules around hobbyist writers
submitting for contest and such well no
because
contests well first of all the writers
strike is resolved so that's the first
thing um it's only the actors
outstanding but to actually answer your
question even if the writer strike
wasn't resolved the writer strike only
applies to uh works that involve the
union so writing contests like for
websites or magazines or for
compilations or Audio Drama or whatever
or even possibly for making a film if
it's outside of the Union's per viw none
of that should be impacted by the
strikes so that shouldn't be an
issue yeah they do address that side of
him well it' be a bit of an elephant in
the room if they didn't modern times is
real modern times is quite good I'll
tell you what's aged uh
amazingly is
um the the last speech in The Great
Dictator holy
crap boy I mean that was incredibly uh
of the time but it's aged
well can I tell you about my trip to
Rose City ComicCon in Portland I don't
know if you got to see Portland beyond
the con hope you'd be interested in a
return visit I didn't really get the
opportunity to you know do Portland
um I I ate out for one meal I had um had
Ramen um at one place but otherwise I
pretty much stuck uh in the hotel room
and uh and ate within a one block radius
um so no I didn't really do the city
that that
wasn't that that wasn't really something
that uh i' planned for and it and like
TimeWise didn't pan out that way it
seemed lovely honestly as a Vermont it
just felt like Burlington it it felt
like somebody took
Burlington put it in phot chop it just
hit the expand feature made it about
three times as big it it had a very
familiar Vibe um have I listened to he
justs at scars it's one of Bonnie
langford's best showings as Mel Bush I
have not listened to that one there's a
fair amount of big finish I haven't
listened to I haven't gotten back to Big
finish in a while um actually there's a
lot on behind
on uh I saw a raccoon the other day
congrats uh have you started watching
anything horror this month yet I'm
currently working my way I'm as of today
I am halfway through Castlevania
nocturn
um yeah I'll have thoughts on that
[Laughter]
later it's mine and my girlfriend's
anniversary this week oh nine years
together we cannot remember which is our
actual anniversary either second or
fifth uh well happy anniversary
regardless Cara that is wonderful I'm
reading a book where aliens invade and
make the entire human race move to the
South
Pole wouldn't all the body heat melt the
melt the ice I don't think that's
actually how that would work but that
was just the first thing that came to my
mind uh once my dad's friends from
Pittsburg visited Portland they
commented that reminded them of
Pittsburgh because of the bridges well
it reminded me of Burlington because of
the just the atmosphere of the
place funny you mention Pittsburgh I
almost went to Pittsburgh this past
weekend but the plans that I'd had to do
that kind of fell apart so that didn't
happen probably just as well I kind of
needed the recovery time rather than to
be doing two uh trips two weekends in a
row are there any raccoons in your area
I mean yeah unfortunately most of the
time if I see raccoons it is uh
apologies uh for for bringing this up it
is as roadkill it is currently roadkill
season around here and in terms of like
what I actually see like around town I'm
far more liable to see a skunk
actually actually my my
kids uh my kid's mother her dog got
skunk sprayed recently so yeah they're
they're around I saw the last Voyage of
the Deiter great adaptation of a segment
of Dracula that many adaptation stand to
cut out it was an interesting concept I
kind of forgot the movie happened after
uh it came out it that is it's one of
those things that
um uh it's one of it's one of those
movies that like if I'm ever like
browsing Netflix and it pops up I might
go oh right maybe I'll watch that but I
probably won't go out of my
way uh the
air the earring Leaf thing looks great
oh thank you uh pick these up at the
Maple Festival in town uh this
year raccoons are notoriously bad for
avoiding cars around here too well
everything's bad at avoiding cars around
here the one thing you really need to
watch out for around here is Moose
because basic anything the size of a
raccoon or smaller you're just going to
be left feeling bad and it does feel bad
I don't mean to minimize that it's been
a long time since I've hit anything but
like it you feel bad when you do um but
you hit say a deer your car is going to
get a lot of damage you hit a moose
you're probably going to die uh because
the thing about moose I if you have not
actually seen a
moose you don't realize how tall these
things are and they've got these spinley
little stick legs so what happens around
here is if you hit a moose on the
highway and your car you will take out
their legs out from under them and they
are tall enough so where as a deer you
take out their legs and they land on
your on the hood of your car maybe roll
up the
um uh the wind screen you hit a moose it
is going to fall onto the top of your
car and Crush
you so yeah that's the thing you really
need to watch out um for around here and
the number one threat to America
Bears have you seen a movie called a man
called aut nope I saw somebody else
watching it on the plane on my way out
to uh Portland I have not seen it it's
not really my kind of
movie
uh what's with the phrase three guesses
in the first two don't count wouldn't
imply that it's something not very
obvious so um it's one of those phrases
where I know what it means but the
exact wording doesn't quite pan out if
you are literally minded because what
it's meant to bring across is a fancy
way of saying you only need one guess
because we're not going to count two out
of these
three but the exact wording still
implies that you're going to do those
first two guesses which muddies the
water on it a cleaner way to say it but
it's not as Snappy is um I would give
you three guesses but you won't need the
second two that would be a cleaner way
to to say what that phrase is meant to
bring across but it's a little clunkier
rolling off the tongue so you
know regrettably I remain unhydrated I
can't find a bottle open in my apartment
no oh that's a tragedy oh my
goodness I'm not even
kidding first part of the book's really
interesting because they outfit a load
of ships to carry as many humans as
possible hygiene and privacy
disregarded not fun
I'm onto series four of the Twilight
Zone I'm not happy that serling's
introduction seems to be filmed in the
same location and not where the story is
set that had never occurred to me then
again I've never watched Twilight Zone
in order I jump around
um
so that had that had not occurred to me
um that that happened in the uh in the
fourth season but yeah I could see that
being a little bit of a disappointment
that shows so good
though it's so
good are moose is the reason Us cars are
so gargantuan no they're so gargantuan
because we are a wasteful people with
tiny egos no I'm sorry massive egos to
compensate for tiny other things uh the
moose population in the US as a whole is
not that big certainly not big enough to
account for um some of the stuff people
drive
let's
see like the Symphony of the sea is
modified to carry 50,000 people
yesh why not I'll give you one guess
that works that works again like when
you get to turns of phrase like that
it's often more about sounding
good the here's the one that always bugs
me because people flat out say this one
wrong so what the phrase should be is I
couldn't care less but so many people
say it as I could care less which means
that you care to some degree cuz if you
didn't care at all then you couldn't
care less I hear people get that one
wrong all the time and it drives me up
the wall
uh you might see me TV andon pop up in
comments again the Doctor Who sci-fi
nerd that's been dormant since I was 15
has been re awoken ha welcome
back uh do you would you consider a top
10 Seventh Doctor stories once you've
seen all of his episodes I mean
maybe um I don't know when I'm going to
catch all this stuff the
only classic aod doctor that I've seen
every story of so far as the sixth
doctor and that's just because he's got
the fewest so that's how that happened
um I mean maybe I don't know I'd have to
think about
it how did I like the latest Doctor Who
trailer no thoughts to share that is
promotional material and the SAG strike
has not yet
resolved what are my thoughts on the
modern landscape of horror better than
it's been in a
while like
we oh boy things were rough for a
while um it feels like horror has gotten
out of its slump of like one single film
defining the
next decade or so of horror movies
because uh in the 90s into the early
2000s it was
scream and it was meta and it was
self-aware and it was snarky and
suddenly slash are back and they're all
meta and self-aware and snarky and then
saw was big and then the first hostile
did well and suddenly everything is
really freaking gross and it's all
torture porn I feel like these days
horror is allowed to be diverse I think
it benefits that it is now acknowledged
so thoroughly as a niche genre with many
niches within it so I I feel like
there's a lot less um tail chasing in
horror than there used to be um at least
it feels that way so I think overall the
state of horror right now is pretty
good
uh it's corn May season it is one of my
partners wants to take me to a corn maze
in two
weeks uh he's very excited about that
and I have done a corn maze before but
thankfully we're not doing the one
that's closest to me which is
so huge like set aside your entire damn
afternoon Supreme Omega in with the
Super Chat thank you so much when did
comic creators start to recreate their
childhood Nostalgia I know it didn't
start in the 2000s with John's and Dio
was it in the 90s the
80s
honestly a as a major movement with
within a significant chunk of of coming
B writers it kind of was the
2000s what You' get prior to that is you
basically get isolated examples so you
get you get folks like um oh God what is
his name Ray Thomas who was super
nostalgic for the old stuff like he did
he created the um the secret
Origins um line at at DC simply so he
could retell all these these origin
stories for all these old Heroes that he
used to love so you had people like him
you know even back in the 70s and the
early 80s but they were kind of
outliers you you had a lot more at least
to my memory in the 80s and the 90s you
had a lot more push to find new
directions as opposed
to find a way to tie in the old stuff
which has very much been this thing
especially over at
DC again since the 2000s with Jeff
John's and uh and Theo
so it did happen before that but it
didn't feel like that was the direction
of uh an entire company back then the
way it has felt for a while
like when was the last time DC
introduced like a brand new character
who they really pushed because I can
think back to the 80s Firestorm got a
real big push back in the
day um and then you know they tried to
push a bunch of them through you know
new Justice League and new stuff like
that and of course Marvel introduced a
whole slew of new crap especially in the
90s most of it was garbage but I think
Marvel does still push new stuff every
now and then not a ton but you know you
still get your Jessica Jones's your
miles morales's your um Camala Khan's
who even in though in two out of three
of those cases they still technically
carry the mantle of an existing
character but it's still very much a new
uh character carrying that I really feel
like DC has gotten terrified of doing
anything new
anymore and it's it's a
shame uh weird house Word Crimes
mentions the could care l thing I forgot
about that it's been a while since I
listened to that
one uh let me
[Music]
see I once saw a display table of
pumpkin spice scented hair and body wash
product at Trader Joe's I thought that
was too
far that's a little bit too Umami I
think as a as a scent to want it on on
my body at least maybe maybe for some
folks I don't know
horror is rising at the expense of
Comedy oh comedy has
been garbage for a long time that's not
even
recent um I would say comedy was killed
with the one-w punch of Jud appau uh
followed by The Hangover
movies have I watched princess week's
video on Martha Jones and Her treatment
by the show not as yet I know it's out
there um and Princess weeks does Great
Stuff I have not seen it yet I know it's
there it's it's in my to watch list
along with a bunch of other things I saw
in cabin of the woods I heard that one's
good that one is good I hate hate the
last five minutes I have a years old
video going off on how much I [__]
hate the last five minutes of that movie
so yep there's that get that off my
chest uh thoughts on the TV show the
boys I have not seen it so I have no
thoughts uh they just showed the Great
Dictator speech I think the major reason
it's so powerful is that it's from a guy
who became famous without saying
anything I would say that's part of it I
think the actual substance of the speech
is also part of why I think that was
probably part of its impact at the time
I think part of why it endures is the
body of it of it
itself there was a pumpkin field that
had a
a cavern filled with cutouts of Alison
Wonderland characters I always remember
that for some reason yeah that's the
that's the sort of thing that would
stick with you I like your mug thank you
I also picked that up at the um local
Maple Festival not the most recent one
I've had this for a few
years and it's a a Stein technically I
believe probably got that
wrong
do you prefer uh Paul Cornell's Doctor
Who or comic writing I'm not sure I've
read any of his comic stuff I've met him
at galr 1 he's a seems like a lovely
fellow my dad used to work on a merchant
ship and when I asked him about the
plausibility of all that he said yeah
that's probably plausible like if you
take a 19th century approach to hygiene
that makes
sense uh what about pumpkin spice
flavored
Doms uh old web shooter I'm not sure if
you mean Doms the way that I'm used to
people meaning
Doms if you do then I then I have
follow-up questions if you don't might
want to
clarify streaming news Netflix PL to
increase their subscription rate once
the actor strike is over oh they were
going to do that anyway they like they
they were going to jack up the price
anyway just like everybody else is
jacking up the price they're just going
to blame the strike so that they can
pretend that they weren't always going
to [__] do this and I apparently I've
decided I'm going to swear this
stream I I need to get one of those one
of those buttons that I can press live
on on stream to bleep myself I know you
can get those I know OT has
one
which of the following Doctor Who uh
episodes for no particular reason is
best une Earthly child the war game city
of death caves of andreani trial of time
L CH of femic KN of the doctor city of
death I honestly could have stopped the
incident you said city of death sketch
comedy to horror pipeline though Peele
from Kean Peele Barbarian director from
whest kids you know ties with satirical
nature of uh new horror wave yeah
uh a little
bit um I think like in a lot of ways
there's there's a lot of I mean Sam Ry
talked about this there's a there's a
lot of bleed over in sort of the
methodology of humor and of horror it's
all about tension and release in comedy
it's building up to the joke until the
punchline the releas is the laugh and in
the case of horror it's the building up
of tension uh of the atmosphere and The
Dread and the release is a scream so
like it's it it's not that surprising
does Cabin in the Woods have an
alternate ending not that I know of the
ending of Cabin in the Woods in the book
was wait there's a
book wait there's a book are you
sure cabin
Woods I
[Music]
uh uh I think you might be thinking of a
different
movie ah okay so it looks like the
closest there was to that was there was
an author named Peter Gallagher who
tried to file a copyright infringement
against against uh Cabin in the Woods in
2015 because of his
novel uh the case got
dismissed so he never got anything yeah
I I think you might be thinking of a
different movie there
homebody watch your review of Super
Mario Brothers movie earlier today yeah
I'm sure you are very quick to tell me
every time you watch one of the things I
have that I put out I appreciate uh your
sympathy I'm currently currently pining
at a bottle of wine I can't get open
oo just get a bottle opener my
friend uh I know Little Shop of hores
has an alter has an alternate ending
that's better in my opinion hot take no
it isn't no it's not it's worse it's
worse for the
movie The uhid the alternate ending for
Little Shop of Horrors is closer to the
stage version but it works on stage
no it's not better it's worse hot take
everyone says the alternate ending for
Little Shop of Horrors is better and
they're wrong
so Canada is the best maple syrup by far
I'm a vermonter them's fighting
words highly recommend Paul Cornell's
demon knight run easily one of the best
new 52 books that's a low bar terrific
fantasy fun with etran the demon and a
non-binary shining night oh oh I did
hear about that um m meddleton talked
about
that oh
nice did uh anyone watch the anime
babyon 5 movie
um uh no spoilers in the chat for that
because I haven't seen it and I won't
until after Jesse and I get back to
jumpgate and finish off Babylon 5
so in DC Cornell did the Action Comics
run that involved Lex Luthor meeting
death huh apparently role playing the
scene with gam to make sure death was
characterized right see I don't I don't
super love it when the endless show up
in the standard books like I know they
can I know it's all established to be
the same world I don't know it could be
good I don't like when they show up
though honestly I generally don't think
it's worth it worst one was Alan Moore
in the case of League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen by that stretch judge should
have laughed that one out of court Le
okay so another hot take that movie is
terrible as an adaptation of the
original work um it's not that bad a
movie it's fun it's
fine
uh do you like scented candles yes I do
oops you're right I'm a crying out
trying to remember the title No Worries
homebody it's kind of mistake I'd make
speaking of bottling I helped my wife
bottle some pear hard cider today ooh
lovely what are my thoughts on Buffalo
Bill preparing for a
rant Buffalo
Bill oh as soon as I answer this I need
to hop over to the Discord uh caroan
told me to set a timer to remind myself
to do that because she is uh very
smart
so here's the thing about Buffalo book
because I assume since you said
preparing for a rant you are are
referring to
um uh you're referring to from the movie
and the book um Silence of the
lamps here's the
thing for the time it was
written it is leaning into what was
already a Troublesome
Trope it
did try to soften its potential impact
on the trans
Community um because you know Hannibal
Lector himself has lines in it flat out
saying and I'm going to use outdated
language because it's the language used
of the movie movies from 1990 just roll
with me on this hctor actually says that
um bill is not an act is not actually a
transsexual and it's noted by um agent
Starling that transsexuals are not known
for being violent so there is an
attempt by the movie to distance the
character of Buffalo Bill from actual
transgender people it doesn't work and
it's ineffective in fact it's one of my
go-to examples for
why you can't just have characters say a
thing and have it impact something that
uh is and have it affect something that
is much stronger presented in every
other aspect because characters say that
but nobody remembers that what everyone
does remember is Buffalo Bill putting on
lipstick and tucking himself between his
legs and looking in the mirror and going
would you [__]
me I'd [__] me and that's what they
remember so regardless of whether or not
anybody in the movie said he's not
actually transsexual and transsexual
people aren't like that nobody remembers
your explanation they remember what you
showed that overrides
the the more uh Placid aspects of
dialogue the visual storytelling
overrides it so I will always cite it as
a strong example of explaining that
point did it do long lasting damage yes
yes it did did it intend to no it it
certainly wasn't the first movie to to
do that like there are movies there are
decades already worth of movies that did
some version of that so Silence of lambs
didn't invent it Buffalo Bill just
became a a particularly memorable
example and it's something that is
weaponized uh as a way to mock trans
people sense and that's not really the
movie's fault the movie has problems but
like I think if you had
told the original writer or the
filmmakers this is going to be the
lasting impact of this character if you
do it the way they did it I think that
they probably would have made some
adjustments they didn't know it's still
a problem but they didn't know so as
long as I've now talked about it
like it's not something worth attention
anymore I don't think it's cabinet the
end of the world the book and the movie
knock at the cabin oh okay I see where
the confusion came in anyway I got to
hop over to the Discord this is your
reminder that the one other way to get
your stuff addressed is to uh be on the
council Geeks Discord with which is an
exclusive perk for patreon supporters at
the $2 and higher level $2 per
month let's see what we got let's see if
I can burn through these I got a call
from DC they were looking to hire me for
something called a speaker they said it
cost 300,000 a year should I take the
job this is a joke um well they if they
told you it costs 300,000 a year
definitely don't take it they should be
paying you that's the nature of a job
yeah I heard about that shortly before
getting on stream that McCarthy was
booted
what a [__] show what are you most
excited about for the upcoming doct
specials and series do you think you'll
watch the Prett Percy Jackson Disney
plus series okay um I should have I
should
have I should have answered the first
question before reading out the
second most excited um for the for the
specials honestly probably
Donna um and for the series I just want
to see how sh got God is going to
characterize the doctor that's what I'm
most excited for I don't have any plans
to watch Percy Jackson I never read the
books I don't really have an attachment
to
it like unless I'm severely caught up on
so much stuff that I'm behind I don't
see myself going out of my way for that
one uh if you were to cosplay someone
from good Omens who would it be I have
everything except a wig to cosplay as
Crowley actually that's not true I do
have a wig but it's bad and I don't want
to use it again um but uh yeah I uh I
have Cowley coso you can actually uh see
it in my review for season two peaches
pears or plums either peaches or pears
depending on my
mood um though that like honestly
depending on my mood I could reach for
one of those uh at a different time as a
preference this is a question I ask uh
I'm asking a lot of people because I'm
trying to figure out if if I have a rare
opinion how do you feel about cassettes
I liked cassettes now I have a very
strong feeling that if I were to listen
to them now I would immediately pick up
on how bad the audio quality is I don't
know if you've tried to watch a VHS like
in the last five years I have holy crap
do they look bad that's not my memory of
it though but I remember
enjoying cassettes I remember enjoying
them uh you know as an experience of an
album where you couldn't just skip the
tracks I think there was validity in
that experience um I ultimately I did
kind of prefer the CD model where you
could skip ahead but I think there are
some things that I wouldn't have come to
properly appreciate if I hadn't had to
listen to the whole thing I mean I could
have fast forwarded but it's it's a peac
meal thing to try and do I think there
were things I came to appreciate more
because I just listened through rather
than trying to fast forward to the next
song uh on a cassette I don't know I
kind of miss them in theory in principle
like again the sound quality I'm pretty
sure if I listen to it would be so bad
I'd be like oh my
God what do you think is the best video
game to make a film version of uh none
of
them like say I talked about this at you
go back to one of the Council of Geeks
scripted short so like before I was even
ranting at the camera like back when
this was supposedly like kind of a sitc
kind of Channel way back so like a
decade over a decade now like 11 years
ago I've been doing this a long time I
did a video where the character I played
argued that uh tried to argue in favor
of some things you know being good for
adaptation uh some of which uh did
actually happen but my actual opinion
was Vo by the character that uh that
Nate
played because he said none of them will
be any good because once you strip the
interactive aspect out the remaining
story is pretty much always
generic what makes it interesting and
makes it engaging is that layer of
interactivity there is more of an
argument to be made I think for series
for like do as a series because some of
the video games with stories that are
more
adaptable that have good are like going
to be longer and more in depth so excuse
me and you know games like that last 20
to 60 hours granted a lot of that is
grind but even you strip out the
grind that's there's not much left to
work with the the problem is most games
with good stories the truly great ones
need to be done interactively the story
would not be told as well here's a good
go-to example for that Bioshock so many
people have said said Bioshock would be
a great movie they're wrong it'd be a
terrible movie because a big part of
that story is environmental storytelling
and it works in a video game because so
much of the story of that world is told
by wandering through it well shut up I
accidentally hit snooze the first time
but so much of the story of that world
of rapture is told by wandering through
it which you do at your own time your
own pace you notice it as much as you
care about because you decide if you
want to take time out from the shooty
bang to learn more about the world a
movie has to have you on tracks has to
either keep you moving forward or turn a
camera to look at the storefront to get
the point it doesn't work that kind of
environmental immersion
storytelling that some games do
incredibly well to strip that out and
just present it l as a linear
story it would not be good at the at the
best it would still be worse than the
original it would be a reduction
I I still stand by the the idea that
there will never be a good or let me
revise there will be okay there will
never be a great like a great movie
based on a video game there can be great
serieses based on video games and we've
seen that with Castlevania with the last
of us but is because they take the room
to breathe to to basically make up for
the interactiv for the lack of the
interactivity so you're no longer in
control where you can just wander around
and talk to all the NPCs you feel like
engaging with but it also doesn't have
to take the story and then cram it down
into two two and a half well three hours
seems to be coming standard they got to
stop that um but anyways stop trying to
make video games into movie make them
into TV shows that has a much better
track record they're now doing a
University degree in content creating
social media influencing if you were
teaching a module for that course what
would it be it would be everything I
teach you is going to be out of date in
two years what the hell do you think
you're going to learn from
me yeah I I don't know how you would
even begin to format a degree for that
because by the time somebody gets the
degree the stuff they've learned in
their first year in that program will be
out of date the it moves too fast like
there are some core fundamentals you
could learn but you don't need like a
four-year degree worth of learning to
learn those fundamentals and the stuff
that you could drill down into like I
said it's going to be Chang by the time
you graduate or if not then within a
year of having graduated like I If I
were teaching for a module what would it
be
I it it would be stop listening to me
and just start making
stuff how often do you think about the
Roman Empire I only think about the
Roman Empire Empire when PE when other
people bring up how much they're
thinking about the Roman Empire and then
I go oh yeah that was a thing wasn't it
favorite seven and eight story I don't
know I was thinking about this this past
weekend I go back and forth between uh
remembrance of the dollx and happiness
Patrol right now although oh greatest
show in the Galaxy's right up there too
like they're just so good they're so
good where would you recommend people
people start with classic who um I'm
going to do a similar recommendation to
what I do to what I've done for people
to to start
with uh modern era watch city of
death I think that is one of the most
accessible Standalone ones um to get a
sense of it and if that worked for you
then
honestly throw a dart board throw throw
a dart at a board and don't throw the
board throw a dart at a board and pick
one like you don't have to do them in
order you absolutely don't these are
largely Standalone stories really except
for um a couple of times they did direct
sequels and Seasons like trial a Time L
and key to time the rest of them can
literally be done in any order
whatsoever
so look at a synops look at a a a a sort
of one sentence synopsis of a story if
it sounds interesting watch
that uh did you ever watch the crater
Mass series if so any thoughts I have
not so no thoughts Hocus Pocus question
uh before you are the costumes of the
Sanders sers which do you pick um is it
Sarah's the bimbo yeah her pumpkin spice
spice latte or pumpkin bread a pumpkin
spice latte pumpkin bread is it's a bit
dense it's a bit much uh what are the
odds of the SAG after negotiations will
go Fairly towards the performers I.E the
wga contract resolution oh it definitely
will it absolutely will yeah it it might
take slightly longer to hammer out I
think because there's a little bit
more um sort of nuts and bolts stuff to
get on top of than the uh than the riter
strike but like it's going to end if not
as favorably as the wrer strike did very
very
close okay last set of three and of
course they're long ones here we go the
other day I met a post about Bigfoot on
Reddit it was inspect fiction related
subreddit so I wasn't actually endorsing
its existence the guy responded told me
he's seen hundreds of Bigfoots and
they're the fallen angels from the B
sorry I don't mean to laugh they're the
fallen angels from the Bible do you
think it's okay to openly mock someone
who says something like this that was my
response and I've since thought was I
making fun of someone with a mental
illness I mean honestly I think by and
large it's best to not engage with these
people if only because you're not going
to convince them otherwise anyone who
agrees with you is going to laugh at
seeing that the same as you
are and there's no need to tear somebody
down regardless of whether or not
somebody has an mental illness like you
don't know I can't know I would say set
that concern aside I would say just be
careful because I think mocking people
for uh expressing what they at least
purport are um are real beliefs that
they have it just risks bringing out the
[__] in you and I'm not calling you
an [__] but I'm saying it's very easy
to come across as the [__] in those
situations so I say just avoid them just
don't respond I mean every now and then
like with a openly transfer phobic
person I'll respond in a slight mocking
way like in my comments but nine times
out of 10 I just block them I just block
them and move on I read a book series
last year about a knight in the 1100s
who murders a man who he knows wants to
kill him then a year later finds out
there was a witness who was going to
tell the king something I've been
wondering since is can you judge someone
in the past in that situation the first
murder was justified would have probably
resulted in torture and death if the
innocent man told the king it took
place um I mean you can judge somebody
for anything and everything because the
thing is like you always have a choice
you don't always have a good choice but
you always have a choice my first
question is uh if he knows he's going to
be reported can't he flee the
kingdom I mean if he's if he's if he's
knighted presumably he has some amassed
wealth he's got armor he's got sailable
skills toss whatever liquid assets
you've gotten a cart and get the hell
out of Dodge so yeah you can judge
people understanding the difference in
circumstances is always valid but yeah
you're within your right to judge people
uh so I listen to a podcast today called
behind the bastards that's about the
worst people in history oh fun something
I found kind of interesting about
today's episode is the guy grew up to be
a fascist but his dad was a progressive
communist and a lot of the early parts
of the guy
autobiography about how as a kid he
wanted to do stuff like own guns he
ended up secretly making a crude one
himself to kill animals and listened to
Hitler on the radio this was before
World War II and his dad's response was
to just forbid him from doing it all uh
as a modern Progressive parent what do
you think is a good way to handle a
situation like that this guy's response
to his dad's STM response was just
Defiance and hiding his activities from
his parents well I mean by and large
within okay within the scope of
understanding of whatever age the child
is at just flat out forbidding don't do
that is almost never a good idea because
that grants it an Allure anything that
cannot be spoken immediately grants a
mque so do I think that the parent was
wrong from uh not letting the kid have a
gun and not wanting him to listen to
Hitler no was it a good idea to decide
to do that by just putting his foot down
going cuz I said so yeah that was
probably a bad idea I think that's a bad
parenting style regardless of what your
principles and beliefs are if your style
of parenting is just you do it cuz I say
so and I will not explain to why then
yes you are going to end up with a
rebellious Kid full stop you just are so
I don't think it's an issue at
all um with what with what any parent
like that what their beliefs actually
are it has to do with the fact that they
are treating the relationship between
parent and child as a dictatorship I
make all the rules you have no say um
and I'm not even going to explain the
rules to you you just listen cuz I say
so I think any parent who does that that
it's going to end up with a resentful if
not rebellious child if not immediately
then down the line once they're in a
situation where they don't have to
listen to every damn thing you think you
know so yeah no that was bad
parenting anyway okay that's it for the
Discord back in the live stream woo we
got a Super Chat Captain Lunar say what
you will about psycho at least they go
out of their way to explain Norman
Bain's not trans at the end of the movie
yeah but it is ultimately the same kind
of thing as Buffalo
Bill most people don't
remember the psychiatrist
explaining that he's not trans they
remember Norman in the dress with the
wig and the knife
going before he gets tackled in the
basement
so it's it's effec ly the same problem
as Buffalo
Bill do you like the song 99 Red
Balloons yeah it's a nice it's a nice
enough song and yes I do know what it's
about before I go I recommend you check
out the 1963 film the
Innocence truly atmospheric
fil truly atmospheric film to watch at
Halloween lovely don't know if I'll get
to it curious what were you watching VHS
for had some old VHS uh tapes with stuff
that I thought my kid would like um that
I didn't that I hadn't re-bought on DVD
so this was
like seven years ago and yeah it looked
like
garbage
uh in light of Netflix closing down the
old DVD service what will you miss I'll
miss finding titles that aren't
available for streaming digital rental
yep I'll miss
that like I I've just got Nostalgia for
that format a bit but what am I going to
be for Halloween no clue no idea do I
like the song Fireflies by I will say
yes I do so McCarthy is out as Speaker
yes he
is which was going to happen because
part of the condition of him getting
that position in the first place was he
had to basically allow in the rules for
his term that it was incredibly easy to
remove him from that position
basically the only way he was able to
get the position of speaker was by
agreeing um to let the extremists fire
him anytime they
wanted and they did
so ah
saw your Tweet about Castlevania nocturn
as the main character kind of a drag
it's not that he's a drag it's that he's
boring right now he's boring he's a
little bit Bland like the rest of the
main cast is a lot more interesting than
he like you know what I actually had
this thought uh while finishing up the
the episode that I saw most
recently here's the problem with
Rector and we'll see if this holds for
the whole way through but here the
problem with RoR in as far as I've
gotten into Castlevania
Octor he has an attitude very similar to
that of Trevor in the uh first four
seasons of Castlevania now I liked
Trevor a lot but the reason that
attitude worked on Trevor was he was in
minimum his 30s I could have bought in
his 40s he was World weary he was he was
a bit of a downer he was a bit of a oh
this is stupid oh why are we doing this
but you got the sense that it was
because he'd just been through so much
crap in his life even though with RoR
they show some of the specific crap he's
been through in his life he is so young
that it doesn't come across as somebody
who has been grounded down by life in
time it comes across like a snotty
brat the there are some attitudes
that can work or not work
um for characters simply by virtue of
how old there are there are certain
attitudes certain characters can have
that don't fly if you're too old or Too
Young if you want if you want the same
thing in Reverse where uh attitudes that
work much better when you're younger but
than older as much as I am a lowkey
defender of rent definitely of the
musical and a little bit of the movie
there is something I will actually Grant
as a legitimate problem with the film
version of rent as much as I love the
original cast they should not have
brought most of them back
because the the characters were in their
30s all of a sudden 30s bordering on 40
in some cases and that was a problem
because in the original version of the
play these characters who are you know
they're Bohemian they're very live in
the moment live in the now live for
today they're in their 20s when you're
in your 20s that may still not really be
a great attitude to have depending on
what that leads you to do but it's a
very understandable sentiment in your
20s when you're in your 30s and still
saying that it's not cute anymore it's
like what is going on and honestly it
can come across as massive privilege
like what are you doing and it impacts
the characters that they're espousing
the same stuff that worked in the
original cast when they were in their
20s then now you've got them in their
30s in the movie and like no those same
sentiments coming out of somebody in
their 30s that doesn't hit right that
hits wrong so same
principle you looking forward to the
Devil May Cry anime
I did not know there was a Devil May Cry
anime coming out I actually never played
those games
so I try not to be that kind of person
but given the past Century in America
never trusted McCarthy I
mean I have no respect for the guy but
right now when it comes to the the
house he's not the biggest problem he's
not even
close a lot of German songs remind me of
the culture because a lot of the culture
discovery of the earth involves that
country interesting it's kind of like
the fifth doctor being grumpy and that
kind of thing works better for doctors
that appear older yeah yeah something
like
that maybe you go out as Jack
Skellington hell no I don't have a suit
that that fits for that and I am not
that good at makeup and I do not want a
hat of a big fiberglass head so uh
no
no uh like catcher On The Rise stops
being edgy and cool once you hit your
30s yeah pretty much I tried rereading
it thought would have spoiled entitle
brat I mean he is I mean he is no matter
what age you are but when you read it
when you're young you can relate to that
mindset but when you read it when you're
older you're like
what a little
[__] what are we talking about we're
we're actually kind of uh winding things
down k i I've still got a bit to go on
this I'm not gonna chug it I don't
think which of the following Doctor Who
episodes uh for no particular reason is
Best Day of the Doctor parting of the
ways GR in the fireplace 11th Hour
heaven sent the Heaven
Sent it's Heaven
Sent
uh chug chug chug no bad idea people are
spreading photos of Peter Capal carving
a pumpkin on Twitter it's so wholesome
a is he kind of give it to a trans
girl if you don't know what I'm
referring to with that joke don't look
it
up I
shouldn't I should not have said
[Laughter]
[Music]
that Castlevania has such amazing
character so I almost feel guilty that
the captain was my favorite by the end
of it no the captain was great you know
who else was great I think it was one of
the night creatures it was kind of the
bugey one that um Isaac had a
conversation with he was
great like there's some great
short-lived characters in that show
that's such it's so good so good I
always saw cater On The Rise pretentious
and pretend edgy back in high school uh
couldn't figure out why the teacher
liked it so
much oh good lord oh okay somebody got
[Laughter]
it by the way are we getting any closer
on those books ah not really I'm look
I'm I'm behind
I'm behind I am flatly behind I had
wanted to have the Audi book edit
finished before the end of the year that
is definitely not happening at this
point
I I'm doing my best I'm behind on
literally everything oh I say literally
everything I managed to still get out my
Saturday videos every week
but everything that isn't that I'm
behind on I just am
I I don't know what to tell you it's not
personal I'm not bumping your stuff
down on purpose I'm not bumping
anybody's stuff down on purpose there's
a lot of stuff that's been waiting a
long [__]
time I'm behind that's
it and I'm not I'm not mad at you for
asking I'm annoyed at myself for that
being the case so if you're hearing
frustration in your voice that is
self-directed uh which of the following
episodes is best fugitive of the Dune
death in heaven Genesis of the dos and
blink
ah the re-evaluation of ss of lambs and
his transphobic elements is a step
closer to us as a society saying yeah
Beauty and the Beast probably should
have won best picture that year well
yeah it should
have it's October 3D it's mean girls day
well tomorrow's Wednesday we wear
pink will I
remember to wear pink on the twitch
stream tomorrow no I
won't
um I love the fact uh that I can share
my name with the central figure that
helped uh an island of Scottish old
religious types Lura policemen into a
large bonfire
oh I
saw I saw the original wicker man for
the first time I think this
year I'm not I'm not necessarily gonna
say that they were right to kill
him
but I was on The Islander side in pretty
much every step of that damn thing
I'm just watching that go the cops the
[__] huh
[Laughter]
okay oh that movie's good that movie is
real good have you ever read anything by
Alex Gino what do you think of them I
have
not uh we read Lord of the Flies catch
on the Ryan junor High when I was a kid
high school I had meteor much more adult
books which would not be allowed now
yeah
wow I read Clockwork Orange in high
school that's a hard one to read like
literally like literally hard to read
Burning Man lifted the idea from wicker
man everything is identical except the
head shape I mean screw burning man but
the Wicker man's a great
movie Supreme Omega swooping in when I'm
trying to wrap up no hate I I love you
in the 20
on the 2000s there's been a lot of
there's been a lot of nostalgia for the
decade thoughts it was very loud
crashing your face area ERA with a grim
edgy tone I don't have a lot of
nostalgia for the
2000s I didn't like the music especially
um it it it
felt in a lot of ways like most of the
deck felt like a trauma
response to um to 911 although to be
fair things were headed in that
direction well before that freaking new
metal happened before that
so [__] me I
guess I said it wouldn't hug it I
lied kind of like BR and wieners oh
there's
a there's a 40% chance it's already
raining which version of the original
was it uh to help me know just tell me
Christopher Lee first where Christopher
Lee first showed up Christopher Lee is
in the
original where I don't I can't remember
I like I don't remember he shows up in a
mansion
when the cop gets there I think that's
what I remember being when he first
showed up I can't
remember can I recommend any Halloween
music
um like songs or like Ambience you want
Ambience honestly uh the soundtrack to
the original Diablo that video game
that's good ambient Halloween music
think Trump will win I don't oh I don't
want to think about it like I I
legitimately do not want to think about
it I don't want to think about the
primaries I don't want to think about
the election I don't want to think about
it that's Karen Smith not Gretchen ah
see I haven't seen the movie in
literally
years uh Supreme
omega as much as we hate Xander was
Willow any
better yeah
like see this is where we get into
arguments over fantasy violence did
Willow go farther than Xander yes the
fundamental nature of who they were as
people Willow was a better person than
Xander Willow fell harder and further
and worse than Xander did in her worst
moments but
like excuse me
her her
normal much better than his
normal what about songs
I I don't know I can't think of anything
that isn't just the generic stuff you'd
hear on any Halloween mix
so go on Spotify pull up a Halloween mix
I
guess Ah that's the original theatrical
cut uh and the other two cuts he appears
outside the pub makes a speech while
watching some snails mating nope that
does not ring a bell
uh anyways I'm gonna wrap it up thank
you everybody for joining me um so uh
stuff coming up tomorrow I will be
gaming on Twitch I'll still be playing
octopath traveler sticking with that for
now we'll see how much longer I keep
doing that for um Friday will be more of
the same for that uh no quill and sword
this week that'll be next week
Saturday's video will be on nimona as an
adaptation I've raved about the movie on
its own merits now you're going to hear
me rave about it as an adaptation and of
course all the other places you can find
me Twitter and Tik Tok and whatever else
under under both Council of Geeks and
under ver wild and uh just be aware if
you're looking at ver wild it is the
nature of a lot of content under that
name is quite different from what I do
here this is the Geeks Focus stuff so
find Council of Geeks follow enjoy have
a good
week remember that you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
mavity